now german leaders are tightening uh
rules for people entering restaurants
who haven't had their booster shots it's
in response to rising omicron infections
uh they've ended a video summit on how
to deal with the infections which are a
third higher than a week ago restaurant
goes who haven't had a third vaccine
will need to present a negative test
the chancellor olaf schultz also says
people with booster shots will no longer
have to isolate if they are considered a
contact of an infected person
well the chancellor uh has held a press
conference so we'll uh let's cross to
our political correspondent simon young
who's been listening in uh welcome simon
so it looks like a tougher rules for
restaurants and cultural events
that's right phil as you said
people who want to go to restaurants
around germany will have to
prove either that they've had three
shots of the vaccine with the booster
or that they've
had two shots or they've recovered and
they've got a
current uh test to show that they're
they're not carrying the disease
so
it's a tough restriction as what uh
chancellor schultz said but he said it's
necessary to get uh control of omicron
they're still worried
although germany he said is in a better
place than many other european countries
and the measures they've had in place do
seem to have been working they're still
worried about uh the wave of infections
that they're expecting
and that's the response that you're
seeing today okay so tougher
restrictions for restaurants and
cultural events but a surprising change
for isolation periods
that's right they've uh they've agreed
to shorten the uh period that people
need to be in isolation or quarantine uh
if they've been infected or if they've
uh had contact with an infected person
uh so that'll go down generally to 10
days from currently 14
or indeed
people who are able to
show a negative test will be able to
come out
of isolation after uh seven days um the
other thing is as you mentioned those
who are boosted will no longer have to
isolate
if they've had contact with an infected
person so
yes they are if you like
adjusting the rules making them
more flexible that's partly in order to
protect emergency services and other
essential critical roles because there
are fears that too much absenteeism
could put pressure on essential public
services
but it's also i think to uh indicate to
people get boosted uh get fully
vaccinated and uh you know that will
help too
yeah it's all it's all about the the
vaccination is it seems to be at the
heart of the the german strategy the
chancellor says he wants to get 30
million more people vaccinated by the
end of the month how they're going to do
that
well they're working on it two and a
half million doses of vaccine have been
administered
over the last seven days but that's not
really enough it needs to be about a
million a day
um so perhaps it's just a little bit of
sluggishness coming out of the holidays
but they definitely need to ramp it up
chancellor schultz
said that that it's proceeding too
slowly and you know all the politicians
um
are appealing to people uh continuing
those appeals to get boosted to get any
dose of vaccine that they haven't yet
had
and you know they say they can do it
they achieved 30 million doses during
december they think they can do the same
in january okay thank you for that simon
political correspondent simon young
well germans do seem to be less fearful
about the health threat posed by the
pandemic and there's more concern about
disruptions to daily life
this is according to the latest findings
from this month's infra test at dmap
opinion poll
coronavirus may be on the rise in
germany but that's not translating into
fear of contracting it
a far more concern is the possibility of
tighter lockdown measures
59 said another lockdown is their
biggest worry
only 30 percent of germans said their
greatest fear is getting infected with
coronavirus
german chancellor olaf schultz's
government is debating whether to
shorten quarantine and isolation times
the public's attitudes about that are
also showing a clear trend
a solid majority of 67 percent think the
14-day isolation period should be
shortened both for people who have
contracted covet 19 as well as anyone
who's come into close contact with an
infected person
both would require a negative test and
no symptoms
according to the polling perceptions of
the government's handling of the
pandemic are mixed
42 think it has struck the right balance
of measures
25 percent say they go too far and 31
say they are not enough that last figure
has fallen by half since a month ago
coronavirus cases are rising quickly in
germany and the omicron variant is well
on its way to becoming the dominant
strain
but germans are clearly less fearful
about contracting the disease and more
ready to loosen some pandemic related
restrictions
let's take a look at some more
developments in the pandemic and global
coronavirus cases have now topped 300
million according to johns hopkins
university
in the united states while it took more
than a year to reach the first 100
million the third 100 million was
reached in barely five months japan is
tightening restrictions in three regions
these are the first
new emergency controls and health
authorities in costa rica say they'll
start vaccinating children
aged 5 to 11 against kovite 19 next week
you